[Music]  thank you Emma and here is Circus armor  Sakia Stamo with his wife Victoria  arriving in Liverpool for the party's  conference and hopefully we can grab a  word with him  really lovely to see you all here and  after 12 long years of Tory failure  didn't they just show their true colors  yesterday  their driving ideology make the rich  richer and do nothing for working people  well this conference is our chance to  set out the alternative to make our case  an economy that works for working people  growth for everyone everywhere wherever  they are a fairer Greener future let's  do it thanks so much  here are you going to reverse the Tory  tax cuts